o sonho não raça que canta para mitigar
os pena pelas hora vividas e perdida nem
que dançou no estudo desse la la notte
todo louca jacinto cantando cancioneiro
desperta emocionei dormidas em mim
muitos morreram um caminho na nossa
souza ba rola luz e de certas e as urnas
bm solidão que foi militar de sempre
sorrindo e outra lá e me séria e é por
isto que cantava nas estrelas e que foi
o vitorioso
sou uma mulher que cantou para
mitigá-las pena não era nada nem na dia
e hora isso que surgiu na estreia
quem me transformando para mim já está
na noite
é
eu escolhi essa canção que é composta
por uma mulher americana
o ferro para uma mulher cubana cantora
de jazz que saiu da lavoura e foi
trabalhar em havana
porque o seu desejo de cantar jazz era
tão grande que ela apesar de trabalhar
em trabalhos como vocês podem imaginar
durante o dia à noite ela cantava ela se
chamava pelo desvio da gouveia ea canção
se chama fred eu descobri essa música em
cuba e escolhi essa canção porque ela
fala de três nações
cuba américa brasil e ela fala das
mulheres e de como é a gente está nesse
mundo e escolhi também para introduzir o
tema sobre o qual eu gostaria de falar e
é a fronteira e quais são as maneiras
que a gente pode arranjar para afrontá
la paz
eu saí do brasil com 22 anos duas malas
na mão sem rodinha em 1978
essas malas estavam bem cheias de de
coisas todas inúteis as roupas
brasileiras não se adaptaram ao clima
europeu eu estava indo pra terra dos
meus ancestrais para a itália estudar
desenho antes de sair do brasil
aqui mesmo em são paulo eu sou nascido
aqui eu já tinha estudado desenho eu era
desenhista profissional sair de casa com
17 anos até os 22 eu fiz várias coisas
trabalhei na televisão tupi tinha um
atelier para crianças por dois anos no
museu lasar segall nós ganhamos melhor a
atividade infantil do governo do estado
de são paulo na época fiz teatro com
artistas maravilhosos tudo e literatura
estudei semiótica enfim uma brasileira
então quando eu saí do brasil já saí com
essa bagagem mas eu tinha também medo de
mim um orgulho nerd já ter uma profissão
de querer estudar desenho já está
preparada digamos né
teoricamente apesar de muitas pessoas
antes de eu sair
tentaram me impedir eu fui até pediram
me pediu em casamento para mim não sair
do brasil sai nã o vai morrer de fome
morreu embaixo da ponte não tem dinheiro
só tá só tem dinheiro para comprar uma
passagem de ida e foi o que eu fiz né
eu fui não acreditando nessas barreiras
então pra mim essas são as primeiras
barreiras digamos que eu tive que
enfrentar sérias que eram geográficas né
e pra isso eu fiz uma canção que compôs
uma canção já quando estava lá e é assim
atrás do trio elétrico só não vai quem
já morreu mas eu tô viva rapaz em são
paulo sonho com havana
vive em tóquio tem passaporte italiano
mario na segunda
sonho com rio de janeiro mas tenho
passaporte japonês
nasci na itália meu sotaque é bem
francês vivo em são paulo
não há quem negue a paraíba sonho com
rio de janeiro mas tenho passaporte
japonês nascido na itália meu sotaque
bem francês vivo em são paulo
e assim foi e lá fui eu com essa bagagem
com meu violão na mão duas malas
quebradas e sem rodinhas e um violão nas
costas ea minha profissão era desenhista
e o meu hobby era cantar e tocar violão
desde os 12 anos
então quando eu cheguei e tive que me
deparar com a situação europeia que era
muito diferente do sonho que o havia
tido né
tive que enfrentar várias dificuldades
então quando me deparei com essa
situação e chegou depois de 16 meses não
tinha mais dinheiro para comer comprar
um pãozinho assim metade na hora do
almoço e tarde na hora da janta
aí eu falei bom tem que arranjar um
jeito de sobreviver né
e eu acabei arranjado um trabalho como
cantora em roma e foi em 1979 que é o
meu hobby virou a minha profissão ea
minha profissão virou hobby
então eu cantava de noite para pagar
meus livros de desenho que eu fazia de
dia os paixão pura
então essa foi a segunda barreira grande
que eu tive que começar a aceitar
dividir que tem a flexibilidade de
aceitar que o meu hobby se tornasse a
minha profissão que minha profissão se
tornasse meu hobby e nesse lugar que eu
arranjei trabalho em roma era um
restaurante vegetariano e eu saí do
brasil ricky macrobiótica tá então sabia
cozinhar cozinhava servia tocava e
cantava até que um dia chegou um senhor
é de uma cidade do norte da itália e me
convidou para trabalhar no local deles
ele era um aficionado df eu tenho uma e
vem de uma família de músicos
meu avô era maestro vindo da itália
meu pai o saxofonista então eu sempre
ouvi muito jazz e ele convidou para
tocar no local dele eu ganhava mais ou
menos cinco vezes mais trabalhava dez
vezes menos
eu aceitei o que aconteceu foi que por
esse destino por essa chance por essa
coisa eu acabei com os tempos 23 anos
abrindo o show de muitos artistas de
jazz importantes que são problemas
ambulift cago samran não sei se alguns
de vocês conhecem esses nomes mas esses
artistas
eles abriram meu coração ea minha mente
para uma grande liberdade que a gente
pode ter no mundo então eu não me
considero
mas já exista mas enfim essa mentalidade
de que é possível a gente improvisar é
verá é verdadeira eu acabei indo estudar
na berklee college of music tem uma
bolsa de estudos lá foi muito bacana
quer dizer não é que eu deixei a minha
profissão que pra mim era uma coisa
excelente que eu tenho me dedicado tanto
pra virar músico e não me dediquei eu
acho que tudo que você escolhe você tem
que se dedicar né
eu saí do brasil pobre muito pobre mas
com muita vontade de aprender
hoje eu falo sete línguas eu tenho
profissão se de japonês e inglês
e como é que eu estudei essas línguas e
não tinha dinheiro
vocês devem saber quanto custa um curso
de inglês ou francês o italiano todo
mundo sabe
hoje em dia se fala mas tem muita coisa
na internet manutd internet naquela aí o
que que a região de um método para
conseguir vencer essa mais essa barreira
que era barreira da língua que ela troca
eu ensinava português
recebi a lição de inglês ensinava
italiano recebeu a missão de francês em
boston e ensinava inglês por japoneses
que não compreendia uma lição em inglês
então eu fui fazendo essa troca eu
recomendo gente funciona funciona mesmo
é que aprendem escreve bota assim no
jornal se olha anúncio o dólar de
português e troca com aula de inglês vai
surgir um monte de gente bacana você
escolhe uma pessoa e você vai conseguir
fazer o que você quer
não é só o dinheiro que capacita uma
pessoa a fazer o que ela quer é essa
fronteira também ela é superável né do
que eu vi hoje aqui é essa é uma
fronteira muito delicada que eu acho que
no brasil eu fico muito triste que isso
exista ainda que é o racismo e nesse meu
percurso eu gravei uma música de arnaldo
antunes que enquanto as pessoas estavam
falando sobre preconceito racial sobre
dificuldades que as mulheres podem
encontrar no mundo ela me veio muito a
mente é é uma letra muito forte e ela
faz assim que branco e pequim do quê
quinhentos que preto e branco que o que
precisa e brancos índios que quebrara
feito uns 15 preto branco ipê branco ipê
que aqui somos mais três mulás carros
patrulha - ara criou os anos têm de
ajudar aqui somos mestiços mulatos
cafuzos próxima - ar acima ou para
licenças ajudar a 10
oriento piso oriento pis e de barzinho
consiga lagoas
oriento piso oriento pis e barry papa
não se consiga lagoas somos o que somos
o que somos somos o que somos
inclassificáveis e eu volto ao tema de
fronteira só para citar um bonito me a
couto que dizia respeito das fronteiras
mentais que em vez de criarmos muralhas
o barreiras quando nós encontramos uma
dificuldade ou uma fronteira pra
atravessar é mais confortável para o
homem criar pontes
aqui isso possa ser possível na nossa
vida e eu queria deixar essa mensagem de
esperança tudo é possível
acredite a fundo